All right, so I'm going
to show you how to get
started working on
Shiny for Python apps.
So this is our
website, at least,
the website in
its current state.
It will be changing
in the future.
You don't have to install Python
and install Shiny and set up
you virtual end
and all that stuff
that you normally do for
developing Python code.
You can just go to our
website and click on examples.
There's some
examples button here.
Or it's in the bar up here.
So I just click
on that, and this
takes you right into this online
Shiny for Python app editor.
So we've got this app code
here, and it's running
the application over here.
And I can make changes to
this and say, "Hi Everyone!"
And I click this button.
We run it, and the app
is running right here.
Now, the really cool
thing is that this is all
running in the web browser.
So this isn't
running on a server,
and you don't have to worry that
if you change this code here,
it's going to change
something on our server.
This is all running on your
computer in your web browser.
So you can feel
free to experiment
with things as much as you want.
Now, over here, there's a whole
bunch of different examples
that you can look at.
So it just starts off in
this really basic one.
It has a slider
and a text output.
I can move the slider, and
some of the stuff here changes.
But if you want to see
how to do other things
and explore other
features of Shiny,
you can look at the
examples from the side.
So another basic example
is an app with a plot.
And it's asking me
here, like, hey, you
want to discard all the
changes to the files?
Because I edited this
app a little bit.
But since I'm switching
to another example,
I'm just going to
throw that away.
And hit-- again, that won't
hurt anything anywhere.
In case, you wanted to keep
the changes on your computer,
that's why it's asking me.
So here is a map with a
plot, and I move a slider,
and this histogram changes
a number of things.
And so you know, you can
make this a little wider.
The layout changes when
it's really narrow.
So this is a sidebar layout.
And normally, when the
window is wide enough,
it'll show the sidebar
content on the side.
But if you make it narrow, then
it flows, so it'll be on top.
And so it will be useful
on mobile devices.
We can look other-- there's
other examples here.
I'm just going to fly
through some of these.
Just to get some idea of
the things that you can do.
So you can have an app
that lets you upload files.
And this shows the code for
how to do an upload, downloads.
I'll skip down to
some of the inputs.
So there's a lot of input and
output components for Shiny.
So this is a text input.
And if I type some
text here, so there.
This input_text gets used
by the server code here,
and it constructs the
string and returns that.
And then, that gets
rendered over here.
All right, so there's
other-- again,
there's other types of inputs
like the numeric inputs,
similar to the text input,
sliders, checkboxes.
If I check it, that would
become true or false.
Checkbox groups.
So I can select multiple
items, and it'll
give me a tuple with
all the selected items.
A Select Input, so
like a dropdown box.
Radio buttons,
text areas, so this
is for multi-line text input.
And there's date
inputs and date ranges.
And password.
It will hide it in the
browser, but that value
gets sent to the server.
So that's some of the inputs.
So for the outputs--
this is actually the
same app as the input
because you type in
something, and Then.
It sends it back to the--
it sends output back
to the browser.
So there's actually
two varieties of this.
There's the text
output, and this
is normal HTML text, the
verbatim text output,
where returns it as code.
Or sorry, code formatted text.
There's UI outputs, which let
you display any user interface
components as HTML.
This component here,
this text input,
is actually output generated
dynamically in the server
and then sent to the browser.
So that's the UI
that's being sent over.
And plot outputs.
So if you need to
display tables,
currently, you can
use a UI output.
If you've got a
pandas DataFrame,
you can have it generate
a table with a two HTML
method on those data frames.
But hopefully, in
the near future,
we'll have a proper
render table output.
There's other fun
little things here,
like different-- there's
a couple different layout
examples and some examples of
how to use various reactive
components.
And then, there's some more
advanced applications that
put various things together.
So here is a Wordle application
that's written for Shiny.
This is one that can use-- if
you load this on your phone,
you can use your phone
camera for input,
and it can do image processing.
So it lets you explore different
types of visual illusions
and play with the parameters.
This is using a
Python package called
Python Illusion, and so on.
So there's all these different
types of examples over here.
Now, let's try to
build an application.
So let's say we want
to explore a data set,
and we can use the
polymer penguin's data
set that's really--
it's a fun and interesting
data set to explore.
So there is a Python
package for this,
and we can just try this out
from here, from this interface.
So I'll just go to
this App with Plot
just so that I have
an app that looks
or that's structured
somewhat like what
I want to do with this
palmerpenguins data set.
I'm just going to type
some code in here just
to try out, to see if it works.
So it's in a package on
PyPI called palmerpenguins.
And the first thing that
I want to do is see,
can s install that package here?
In this particular
setting, where
we have Shiny running on
Python in the browser,
we can use a lot of Python
packages, but not all of them.
So if you want to find out
if your particular Python
package can work here, we
have to use something called
micropip that's
specific to Pyodide,
which is Python in the browser.
So what I'd say is, import
micropip and micropip.install
("palmerpenguins").
Now, I've typed it up here.
This is the Code Editor,
and I can run it.
I can take this--
I can use this editor and
run it line by line down here
or I can select the text and
just run it all as blocks.
If I select text, I
can hit command Enter,
and it runs it down here.
This is our Python--
this is the Python console, and
it looks like it installed it.
So let's say, import
palmerpenguins.
OK.
Yeah, so it installed it.
And then, now, I imported it.
And I could do stuff with it.
So that's the first
thing I need to do
to see if it will install.
What I can do now is I can
say, click on this button.
This will open the project
files that are currently
open in a new window.
So there's only one
file, just this app.py,
and it's open in
a new window here.
And I can edit this
here but still go back
to this window or this tab
and browse the examples.
Let's take a look at this
palmerpenguins data set first.
So I'm just copying
and pasting some code
from the palmerpenguins'
website on GitHub.
So if I just load all
this stuff like this--
so again, I'm running
it in the console
here so that I
can explore with--
I can explore the data little
bit before I go back to the app
and actually try to put
this code in the app.
So penguins is--
let's load penguins,
and then take a look at that.
OK, so this is a
dataframe with a bunch
of columns and 344 rows.
You know what, why don't we
just try putting a plot in here.
So we have this histogram
from this other thing,
from the example.
And let's just try
replacing it with the plot
from the palmerpenguins data.
OK, so this is all--
we move this import stuff
all the way to the top here.
And I load it in here.
I'm going to replace
that plotting code.
And let's see here.
Let's try putting
in a histogram.
So the return g.
So I've edited my app, and I can
just hit the Play button there
and rerun it.
OK, here, the pellet list has
the wrong number of colors.
See, that is because I
played with that a little bit
before I pasted it in there.
Let's try this again.
OK, so here we have a histogram
of these different penguins,
of the three different
species of penguins,
and their body masses.
So we can see that there's
a lot of Adderley penguins,
and they tend to be smaller
than the Gentoo penguins.
And there's also
Chinstrap penguins
which look like they're roughly
the same distribution of body
mass as the Adderly ones.
So it's kind of interesting.
The reason the
colors are funny is
because they're
semi-transparent here,
and they're overlaid
on top of each other.
But let's say we want to explore
the histogram for each species
individually.
Let's try filtering
out by species
and creating an input that lets
you choose which species you
want to see the histogram for.
So in order to do
that, let's take this--
don't need the slider anymore.
We don't need this text output.
So instead of the slider, we
want to add a ui.input_select
("species").
And this is our label
here, "Choose a species."
And I'm going to refer
back to the examples just
to see how this works because I
might have trouble remembering
it off the top of my head,
how to use the select input.
So yeah, we don't need that.
So actually, you
know what I should
do is, I'll just
copy and paste this.
So I'll take this
and put select.
Instead of typing in there,
I'll just paste that there.
And I can modify how I see fit.
So again, we're going
to call the species.
Species.
So on the left here of each
of these key value pairs,
this is the key.
This is what we'll use.
It'll show up in
the code down here.
And this is the text that will
be displayed in the browser.
But I'm actually going
to use a shortcut.
So I know that
you don't actually
have to do it that way.
If you want those, the label
and the value, to be the same,
you can just say Adeline.
You can give it a list
instead of dict there.
Gentoo, Chinstrap.
And now if I want
to filter out--
use this input to
filter out the data,
I can do something like this.
I can say, let's call
this my filter data.
I'll call it p equals penguins.
And let's see,
equals input.species.
And then I have to
put parentheses there
because I'm invoking
this as a function.
So this input.species, that
corresponds to this species
up here.
That's how I fetch the value.
OK, so then I'll take--
I'm storing this in p.
So I want to plot p.
And if I hit--
if I rerun this app,
now I get the error,
the palette list
has the wrong number
of colors because there's
three colors here,
but there's only one species
now that it's being filtered.
So I think I'm just going
to try commenting that out
and see if this works.
So that was-- oh,
I used a key press
for that, a keyboard shortcut.
That's command slash.
But you can just put a
pound sign in the front.
And here we go.
This is the histogram
for the Adeline penguins.
Let's see if this
actually works.
Gentoo, nice, and Chinstrap.
OK, cool.
So one thing that's not so
great about this particular app
is that the x-axis keeps
shifting, and the y-axis,
as well.
So it's hard to compare
them across species here.
But I won't bother trying
to fix that right now.
But you can see
here that this is
a really nice way of
being able to export
your data interactively.
And we did that by just starting
with the examples over here
and just copying and pasting
the code that we needed.
And I can clean this up.
There's all this,
a few other things
that were not needed anymore.
This reactive.Calc
and this render text,
all we have-- all we really
need here is this plot.
I used the
palmerpenguins data set.
But I actually installed
it manually using micro pip
earlier.
It's continuing to
work because it's still
running the same Python
session where palmerpenguins
was installed.
But if I were to take this
and open this in a new window,
let's see what it does.
This is a new Python
session that doesn't
have palmerpenguins installed.
And it says there's
an error starting app.
No module named palmerpenguins.
There's a way to fix that.
I'm going to close this.
And that's by adding
a requirements.txt.
So it's the same format as what
you'd normally use in Python.
So I'd call it requirements.txt.
And I create-- I clicked on
this plus to create a new file.
And then I renamed it up here.
It starts by default
with some Python content.
And we'll just delete that.
And I'll just say
palmerpenguins here.
That should be all that I need.
And now I'll try opening
it again in a new window.
And because it's in
the requirements.txt,
when this app loads,
it'll go and it'll
install the package from PyPI.
And here we are.
It's showing.
It has the data set.
And we can explore it.
And after I've
been working on it,
I might want to save
the work that I've done.
So I can do that by
clicking on this button,
Save all the project
files to disk.
Now this is currently
only supported in Chrome
and in Microsoft Edge browsers.
It doesn't work in Safari
or Firefox right now.
But I'll show you
what you can do
if you're using both browsers.
So I can save this, Save
all project files to disk.
It'll ask me if I'm
sure I want to do this.
And then I select a
directory on disk.
I'll just create a new
directory for this.
I'll call this
penguins, create that.
And I'm selecting the
whole directory, so not
individual files.
So I'm in the directory that I
want, which is called penguins.
Hit Select, and it
saved the files there.
So in the future, if I come back
to this editor or the examples
page-- let me just open
up another editor here.
And this, it starts with
the default basic app.
But if I want to use--
if I want to load
my previous work,
I can just click on this
one, this button here,
to load a project.
And it'll ask me if I'm
sure I want to do this,
to close all the current files.
And I've selected the
penguins directory.
And there.
It loaded the files.
It would have been in a
different order up here.
But they're all still here,
and it's running the app.
Now, if you are using
Firefox or Safari,
another thing you can do is just
click on this Download button.
And this will download the file
to your download directory.
And if there's multiple files,
it'll put them into a zip file,
and then it just saved it there.
All right, so after you've
been working on this app
and you've got
something cool you
want to share with somebody, you
can click on this Share button
here.
This creates a share link.
And with this URL here, if
I click on Copy, and then
I can send this to somebody.
Now it's 937 bytes long.
So it's a reasonable size.
It's not too big.
If I paste it up here, somebody
else can visit this URL.
And they get this same interface
where they can edit the code
and see the app
running over here.
Or you can just copy
this application URL,
which is just the app
by itself, running
by itself without the editor
and the terminal down there.
And I'll paste it here.
And here it is.
Here's my app, just
running by itself.
Again, that whole thing is just
encoded directly in the URL.
So for this
particular case, we're
using some packages
like seaborn and pandas.
Then these ones are included
with our distribution,
which includes shiny.
And it's built on
top of Pyodide.
But because we had
to add palmerpenguins
to the requirements.txt,
it actually goes
and it fetches that from
the PyPI repository.
So every time somebody visits
this website, this URL,
it has to go out and
fetch that package.
So just bear that in mind.
So let's say I've shared this
application with somebody
and they want to
experiment with it.
In this tab, I've loaded
this app from that URL.
And let's just say I'm
another person who's
now playing with this code.
And I'm looking at
this and I'm like,
this stuff isn't necessary here.
Let's clean that up.
Let's change the
text a little bit.
Like, let's say, "Which
penguins are your favorite?"
All right, let's delete that.
Oh, and let's clean
up this palette thing
because we don't
need that anymore.
We can actually--
there's also a button
here to reformat the code.
So let's just do that to
make it look a little cleaner
and nicer.
And hit Play.
OK, so which penguins
are your favorite?
Somebody else can play
with it, make some changes.
And they can click
on the Share link.
And it, again, encodes
this app code into the URL.
And then they can pass
that on to somebody else.
So let's do that.
Let's load that here.
So all that extra code
at the top is gone.
And that commented
out part is gone.
And it says, Which
penguins are your favorite?
You can explore shiny this way.
Again, you can edit it.
You can go back to
the example browser
to see if you want to
try something different,
like instead of select input,
I want to do radio buttons.
Functionally,
they're very similar.
But the interface is different.
The user interface is different.
But let's just put that here.
Input, radio buttons--
I think this will just work.
Yeah, so you can just choose
Adeline, Gentoo, Chinstrap.
It does the same sort of thing.
And you can look
at other examples
to see, to try different things.
If you want people to
be able to upload data,
you can look at this example.
If you want to fetch
data from a remote API,
there's another example here
that shows how to do that.
So you can fetch data
and put it in your app.
And you can go back and forth
between these examples here
and the code that
you're editing,
which is over here now.
All right, and after
you're all done with that,
you can save your work and work
in a normal Python development
environment where you
have Python installed
on your computer and
shiny, and then you
run shiny from the command line.
And that will actually--
that allows a greater
range of things that you
can do than when you run it
in the browser.
But running it in the
browser is a really nice way
to just get started
and try it out
without having to go through
the trouble of installing
a whole bunch of packages.